hello everyone
welcome to rational science directly
from frankfurt germany
and uh we're the only site on the
internet that does
physics
what does everybody else do
well they do
mathematics
what is mathematics
mathematics is
irrational explanations irrational
mechanisms
physical mechanisms
and what is irrational well irrational
means you're going to be moving concepts
around
you know some people wave the wave
other people transfer energy
others excite the feel
and then others
they bend time
scary stuff
that's what they do and that's how they
explain
the workings of the universe we don't do
that here here we do it with objects
and today we're going to be talking
about a fellow in his name a gentleman
who
uh writes profusely for quora the
question and answer site his name is
victor toth we'll be talking about him
and yes he's a mathematician he does
everything by magic
but the important thing about him is
that he passes on what he learned
throughout his life
regarding
the establishment
he's uh
i guess an advocate for the
establishment
so we'll be talking about him later on
but we start with a subject that we left
off the other day and that's
um the moonies and the loonies who are
the moonees muniz are the people who
believe we never went to the moon and
humans never stepped on the moon
who are and we're not going to deal with
them today uh and who are the loonies
people we will
deal with today the loonies are people
who say or think or believe
that the moon spins
and
we're going to set them straight today
okay
so let's begin with them but where do we
begin well we must begin with
definitions
that's where science begins at
definitions you get you have to get the
keywords
straight before you can talk
intelligently
we have to be on the same page in order
for you to understand
the uh
mechanism that i'm going to convey to
you okay so that's the issue
okay so let's begin with the definition
the first definition is the word
definition we have to define what a
definition is what is a scientific
definition
that's where we start
okay and there you see it it's a
limitation placed on the extent of a
usage of a word
okay i always give the example
uh rotten example really it's a lousy
example but i think it drives home the
point to me most people out there and
that is that um
you know i can say it's big it's white
it's got wings
and what am i talking about am i talking
about big bird or the white house
you know and after you know i i keep
adding things like you know it's got
it's a building it's got columns etc
president lives there then you know you
know you're talking about not big bird
but the white house okay so that's more
or less what we're referring to here
okay a scientific definition is rational
if it can be used consistently
throughout your dissertation
okay or throughout your groups
theories
right if one guy uses one definition the
other guy in your same religion your
same congregation uses a different
definition well we might have a little
bit of a problem okay
definition is not equal to meaning
definition is what the prosecutor
spits out and
meaning is what the jury
receives okay the
meaning is on the receiving end so you
cannot use the word defini
meaning to define the word definition
that's the point they are not synonyms
okay but in ordinary speech people use
these words interchangeably they don't
even know what they're saying in science
we have to be very careful okay and
you'll see why
today especially
concepts we define objects we point to
you don't define chair you don't define
table you don't define rock you don't
define tree or dog
you point to them so that the klingon
who just came to your planet to visit
you understands or learns your language
your your nouns so you point name
say you know like adam
probably did you know god put him there
he had to name all the animals so you
know you point a name that's the way
it's done in physics okay and the object
has to be a standalone object
i always make a point of that because
people miss that and that's a very
important one it can't be a dependent
object you cannot
say halo that a halo is an object
and i'll tell you why because you know
you need the angel
see
all you have is really a ring or a plate
there that's it
but a halo is a holy ring a holy plate
and the only way you're going to get it
to be holy is to put the angel in there
so the halo is in that sense is a
dependent object it needs the angel in
order for you to call it a halo
otherwise it's just a ring or a plate
and the same with uh
in physics you know you can't bring a
magnetic field
stand-alone magnetic field and put in
the middle of the conference you need to
bring the magnet with it
or you know the earth if you're going to
talk about a gravitational field so no
field is not a physical object not a
stand-alone physical object
okay so people treat it as a concept as
an object and it's really a concept
and again it's a dependent
uh object in that and that
turns it automatically into a concept
okay
uh anyways only strategic words are
defined we don't define every word in
the dictionary people say bill
you say that an object is that which has
shape yeah
and he said what do you mean by shape
well that's first of all it's funny that
you did not ask me what did you mean by
that
or by which
or by has
i mean is it easier to define that
than shape
i challenge you i mean you know you
can't even look up in the dictionary
probably won't understand the definition
in there but uh it's much harder to
define those words but anyways the point
is we don't define every word in the
dictionary to please the devil's
advocate okay we define only those words
that we
that are necessary and why don't we
define shape because we don't need to
define shape all we need to define is
the word object and an object
uh right now we have a definition from
the mathematical establishment and
they treat it
whether they define it that way or not
because they have many definitions they
define it as that which has volume that
which has mass that which moves
that's we can use which can be used in
the
as a subject of a sentence
they have all these definitions but the
primary one that they use is see and
touch
and so they say an object is that which
you can see and touch
and so all we are doing here is saying
look you got the wrong criterion or
criteria
an object is that which has shape for
the purposes of physics not that which
you can see and touch
not all objects can be seen or touched
especially the table that the klingon
has on the other side of the plan of the
universe
okay you can't touch that one or see it
does that mean that table is not an
object because you can't see or touch it
besides it's subjective whereas shape is
not an object has shape even if it's the
only object in the universe that god
made you know or the devil whoever
okay so operational and functional
definitions they're out they're
unscientific we don't use those it's
that's again
a
custom of mathematics that they say oh
this is a uh an operational definition
it's a functional definition so they
give you their whole dissertation and at
the end of it they say okay this is what
i meant
by that word
that's how they that's how they define
words they define it through an
experiment
like the result of an experiment and so
on now that's an unscientific definition
so we don't use
uh operational or functional definitions
either
okay
okay moving on here
so what's the issue the issue is the
word spin
people say does the moon spin does the
moon not spin and people have no idea
mathematics the religion of mathematics
has taught them that the moon spins why
does the moon spin they say well because
it rotates around the earth in 27 days
and throughout that time you know it
takes one
turn completely around and so they're
saying it it does spin it doesn't spin
like a top it takes 27 days to spin but
it turns one complete time around its
axis
that's the logic that's uh what
or you can call it illogic
and why is that because they haven't
defined spin
so what is the
word spin according to mathematics
according to our current thought out
there ordinary speech okay here you have
it i pulled it out the other day i'm
gonna go quickly uh spin to turn on
around an axis that's all they say
that's very
quite straightforward okay some people
put some more adjectives in there but
that's the essence of it and you look at
the synonyms rotate gyrate uh to circle
tutorial world spiral etc
and
pretty much people use these words
interchangeably
the problem is when you get to the
bottom right there where you say see
orbit is the orbit the same thing as
spin
that's the question we're going to
analyze is there a difference between
orbit and spin
and some people are not quite sure let
me show you one case here a fellow
wrote and he says
my understanding is that the moon does
not rotate around its axis
does it rotate around the earth's
axis
this is a very interesting question it
is an important question and in order to
uh address that issue well we need to
know what that word spin means okay
and so yeah the moon uh
doesn't uh he accepts that it doesn't
spin around its own axis but it says
does it spin around the earth's axis for
this we have to define the word spin
scientifically so that we get rid of the
definitions of mathematics okay so let's
define
this word scientifically so we are so
that we're all on the same page it
doesn't mean you have to agree
you don't like the definition you have
only one recourse and that's to
come up with your own definition get
inside the ring with shield and sword
and defend it
that's the way it works in science it
doesn't say well all my buddies they
voted for my definition
no no we don't care about democracy we
don't care about tradition
we don't care what you've used always we
care about what you can defend
in the ring okay so get in there in the
ring with your shield and sword and
defend your definition okay here's my
definition okay spin 3d yeah i pulled
this out the other day so you can look
at the previous video and get more in
depth on it but the point here is
circular motion of an object's surface
around what it's fixed
fixed
axis
the axis has to be fixed if the axis
turns
with the object with the thing that you
that you're analyzing and the thing that
you're saying is
spinning right if it turns with the axis
at the same rate
it's not spinning
okay so that's the bottom line now
people say
well bill you're crazy
what do you mean an axis is one
dimensional
ah
so now we're going to get into the
nitty-gritty we're going to show these
people where they've they're mistaken
they have been misled
okay
okay so let's get to the nitty-gritty
okay here we have and so here we have a
few more
issues so let's put them all together
here one fellow says what do you mean by
stating the mu the moon rotates together
with its axis but the earth does not
rotate with its axis how does something
not rotate with its axis
so he he's putting his finger on the
right problem okay this is the problem
people don't understand
what's happening here and there i'm i'm
showing you
a little axis it's a three-dimensional
axis
okay and i color-coded it so that you
can see something right again it's just
for the sake of understanding okay
and you can see the one on the left
that's the
correct one the axis turns together with
the moon okay so there's uh it's always
you know the the moon doesn't change its
locate the surface any point on the
surface of the moon is not changing its
location its distance or anything with
respect to any point
on the
on the axis there it could both rotate
at the same time so it always maintains
that distance that you know that
separation whatever
on the other hand the one on on the
right is wrong that's not how the moon
twirls okay it doesn't twirl that way
because
if the axis is standing still then that
any point you have on the surface
changes its location with respect
to whatever point you want on that axis
okay so this is a 3d notion okay we're
going to start with that we're going to
go slow here okay so that people
understand we're not here to make you
believe we're here to make you
understand that's all we're interested
in
okay and as the fellow continues he says
uh discussing whether or not an axis
co-rotates is misleading
these types of axes are for our purposes
one way or the other merely theoretical
concepts
very interesting
point okay
with a with no real life application no
actual rod at the center of any
celestial body that i know of in the
first place
okay so he says uh
i guess i'm not allowed to put a rod in
there
to make my case he's saying because
there is no real rod in the center of
the earth or the moon for that matter
and so to talk about the twirling of the
rod or not or the rod standing still
while the surface of the moon rotates
with respect to the rod well he says
it's um it's um
too abstract or not real or it's it's
it's misconceived okay that's what he's
saying
okay
we uh hold on to that point here's
another fella and he puts a comment he
says if the moon was the seat of a swing
okay
and the earth was the bar on which it
swings
swings on
and the swing did a 360 degree rotation
of uh
the bar the earth in this case right the
standing for the earth
then the sea
moon does not spin
and so the issue here is that is that
guy spinning or is he orbiting
well all we have to do is as long as you
stick to the definition
i promise not to hurt you right how do
we teach in the bill gates school of
physics we teach with a baseball bat
and i can't use a baseball bat here
because it's too long so i use my dough
roller i i hope you don't mind okay it
does the same damage
okay so is this guy spinning or is he
rotating well you gotta spin with
respect to your own axis okay and uh
that axis doesn't belong to the guy
okay
so he is orbiting he is not spinning we
use this in ordinary speech and say oh
he's spinning he's spiraling etc etc
rotating
we separate two words only spin in orbit
he is orbiting he is not spinning
according to the definition okay
so just clarifying that
this is an interesting point
and here we have i think uh
uh
flat earther okay
we do have our flat earthers here if i
can find oh here
i got to show this always okay here we
have a flat earther
and what does this slather say says i
believe in freemason hollywood
productions
uh nice computer animations referring to
one of my uh videos in the past any real
findings uh any real footage
and yeah the problem here is uh people
think that this is a question of see
touch
they say can i see a footage and actual
footage
well usually the problem with flat
earthers is that even if you show a
footage real footage they say well that
was made in hollywood that wasn't out
there
because if if we went to the moon or
even into outer space somewhere or even
send a probe out there without a human
right well that probe can take a picture
or film the earth or the moon from afar
and you say well it's round and it's
spinning i mean you could do it just by
looking
and so they have to deny that we went to
the moon that we went to outer space etc
fine
the way we do it in science we don't we
don't go out there because we can't all
go out there and verify with our eyes
and hands or whatever the way we do it
we stay here on earth and we use our
brains
okay
and what we do is conceptualize
so we don't need to see
okay
the way we do it in science we cut off
our hands and we close our eyes okay
that's the way we do it that's how we
start and once you do that you're safe
because now you're going to use your
brain to visualize
okay what's going on on out there and of
course a flat earther what he's got to
do is explain gravity
and he can't explain gravity which they
can't
not in a rational way well they're dead
you know they're dead in the water
okay so where do we start uh with this
spinning thingy well we start with the
gentleman his name was herman whale
vile in german he was a german guy
and
whale he was a mathematician he was a
contemporary of
uh albert einstein okay
in fact they were almost uh they died in
the same year they were almost born in
the same year and was i think like six
years older than him
and so they lived pretty much together
in you know throughout the same period
of time
and uh wow
whale
um
he he was a fan of einstein he was a
relativist and he wrote a book
space-time matter okay where he analyzed
einstein's uh theory
and he was a friend of mine said he was
also a friend of schrodinger by the way
uh a little more friendlier with his
wife
he slept with with schroedinger's wife
while schrodinger
swept slept with some other wife and uh
if you would have confronted them they
would have said it's um
it's relative
it's all relative and that's how the uh
theory of relativity got popularized
everyone had to do everybody wanted to
do relativity okay yeah
and so what does mr wales say or do well
here it is uh this is from his book okay
space-time matter and he starts by
laying the foundations for uh this
geometric theory known as general
relativity and so he says the following
which takes us to the subject matter
today which is the axis okay so to every
point p of s there corresponds one
definite homologous uh point p of s
which after the above displacement to a
new position that's the one i want you
to focus on displacement to a new
position right would be surrounded by
exactly the same part of the given uh
content as that which surrounded p
originally we shall call this
transformation a congruent
transformation okay
he defines what a rigid body is he says
we mean one which however it be moved or
treated can always be made to appear the
same to us as before if we take up the
appropriate position with respect to it
and there he has a big error and it's
the big error of mathematics and that is
that they introduce an observer which
makes it subjective we can't use this
definition in science sorry mr uh whale
vile whatever
and um
so he can't use this definition because
he's introducing an observer he says
it's got to do with how you see
something so if one guy is drunk another
one has shot up with cocaine and the
other guy you know is
upside down well they're all gonna see
something different okay so what are we
talking about okay so no that's not what
a rigid body is uh but let's continue
here it's just important in the sense
that he's saying that it's got to do
with distance
all all uh particles comprising your
body have to be at the same distance
when you move it and that's kind of he's
going to call that
a rigid body so he defines a straight
line and this is where we get into the
axis region okay it's distinguishing
feature is that it is determined by two
of its points okay
thus if a and b are two different points
the straight line includes every point
and he continues on there okay then he
says the straight line lies evenly
between its points expressed
kinematically meaning with motion right
this is tandamount to saying that we
regard the straight line as an axis of
rotation
so what's the problem the first problem
here that we have with uh mr well's
definition which is the one we have
inherited all the way to mr euclid
is that they never tell you what a line
is
is a line a row of apples
or is a line the rolling of one apple
down the street
is motion a line is an itinerary a line
and this is where we run into trouble
with mathematics because mathematics
treats them all as synonyms
from a physical point of view
uh you know the motion of one object is
not the same thing as
a an object that is stretched a bubble
gum that is stretched
okay or many many apples or whatever
okay so here we have a a little bit of
problem okay especially when mr weil is
gonna whale is going to construct his
line
with points
and he says his line is one dimensional
and his points are zero dimensional so
he's constructing his one
one-dimensional line with zero
dimensional points
and i'm not smart enough i can't
visualize either one of those
okay that's gonna be part of the problem
here yeah i guess the problem is with me
right okay
uh so he continues okay and he says we
may say that the straight line is
derived from a point by an infinite
repetition of the same infinitesimal
translation in its inverse a plane
however is derived by translating one
straight line along another in the case
of rotation for example the points on
the axis are distinguished by the
property that they preserve their
positions in other words if you're going
to rotate something the important thing
is these positions these distances with
respect to that axis
that's what that's what the notion that
people have today
of
what spin is what rotation is
and here i've illustrated uh essentially
what uh mr
whale says about um
both the point and the line okay this is
how he constructs
his line first of all this is the this
is the point constructing the line
okay so he says that a line is something
that is the motion the translation of a
point okay that's what he's going to
define even though he says a line is
defined by two points and then he says
that it includes all the points in
between all the apples in between what
is he talking about is he talking about
points or locations is he talking about
positions
position is a concept a point meaning a
dot right is an object so
the reason all these people can't define
the word point or line is that um uh you
know what what they're doing is they're
missing mixing concepts with objects the
dot is a is an object the
uh position
is a concept and what they have is the
uh dot position and they say that they
call that a point and you say well which
one is the point is the point the um the
dot or is it the location which one is
it and that's where they run into
trouble because you know they illustrate
it with a dot and they call it a point
and they say it's zero dimensional even
though
a uh position is non-dimensional you
can't talk about the
location or position of a concept and
the dot is two-dimensional
so uh with that they construct a
non-dimensional point okay he doesn't
stop there he says how do you construct
a plane well you take that same line and
now you're going to move it downwards
and now you're going to paint or you're
going to scan
a plane okay this is how mr whale
especially
not only him i mean everyone since the
days of euclid has been doing the same
thing they've been scanning
these geometric fix
figures and constructing uh objects of
higher dimensions okay so this is where
we start
okay what's the problem with all this
why has everyone from euclid even before
euclid euclid was a student i guess of
aristotle there because if you look at
the time frame we don't know exactly
much about euclid but he probably lived
in athens first studying in athens at
the time there he had the um
what is it the lyceum of uh aristotle
and uh then he came to
alexandria
uh not virginia but
egypt and that's apparently where he
spent the rest of his life
but uh yeah since the days of euclid all
the way to today
okay
what have all these people been doing
well they've been using euclid they've
been doing you know the same type of
geometry they've been scanning things
and constructing higher dimensional
objects by scanning by moving objects by
translations okay
okay so what's the problem with all this
well let me tell you what the problem is
uh
if if whale is right
when if you want to look at spin
you got to look at if the object
is changing its
distance with respect to
the axis uh some axis in the center okay
so if something moves completely in a
perfect circle right around an axis the
axis is one dimensional right
the object has to maintain the same
distance no matter where
and let's assume the moon does that for
example with respect to the axis of the
earth okay
then yes you can say that the moon
is uh spinning around the axis of the
earth which is one of the questions
that a fellow asked there
what's the problem
in physics there is no such thing as one
dimensional object there's no such thing
as a zero dimensional object there's no
such thing as a four dimensional object
there are only two types of uh
objects
and
they are 2d and 3d
okay
and so there is no serial d no 1d axis
okay especially the 1d no 1d axis there
you see the 1dx that's what it looks
like like nothing
what are you going to put because as
soon as you make it a little wider you
got the 2d that's the problem so those
two belong 2d and 3d those belong to
physic you can talk about those you
can't talk about a 1d axis in physics
only in mathematics in the religion of
mathematics can you use the 1d axis the
notion this concept okay
and we're going to be talking about spin
you can't talk about spin
with respect to concepts
1d
line as they call it is a concept and
again we don't know if it's a bunch of
apples or an itinerary
okay but
for this purposes they say well it's a
bunch of apples
you know you have all these apples all
these points one right after another and
they build the line and we're going to
hold them still so that you can maintain
your distance with respect to each one
of those points that's the notion they
have
but the problem is there is no 1d or in
in physics
and if you're going to talk about
spinning especially about the
spinning of the moon or the spinning of
earth you better talk in three
dimensional terms
okay so just bear with me a second here
i'm just gonna go through this you reach
your own conclusion okay uh we're gonna
start here okay we're gonna get rid of
these two other axes
okay
uh three other there was the four
dimensional one as well didn't touch
that one not important
okay and i'm going to color code them a
little bit okay there it is
and the color coding is just so that i
can show you
visually you know what's going on here
okay uh
again all this is just for the purposes
of understanding the theory the the
concept behind the argument that i'm
gonna present today okay okay so we have
this 2d and the 3d barber pole there
okay
okay what are we going to do we're going
to draw a circle around the their bases
okay so there's a circle around uh the
2d
plane okay this elongated rectangle okay
that's what it is that's what you're
staring at objective it's whatever you
stare at that's what it is in physics
there's no you know
no run around
we don't talk about energy we don't talk
about
fields because nobody knows what those
are no we we show you what it is we're
talking about a plane okay that's what
it is two dimensional plane that's all
you got there okay you're staring at it
uh face forward right
and we're going to draw a circle around
it there you have it 2d we color coded
it red and blue
and now we're going to put in that
environment a ball okay so we have a
ball in there now okay
and what are we going to do with this
ball well as you can see by the green
circle we're going to run it around
we're going to
go around that thing we're going to find
out if uh
if the distances change
okay
so let's measure the distances and again
we don't need to have numbers here all
we need to know is separation the
distance of physics not the distance of
mathematics distance of mathematics is
distance traveled and it's measured in
meters
seconds if you do it with a clock right
but it's measured in in meters it's
measured in um
uh
feet inches you know those are the units
we use that's not what distance is in
physics in physics it's separation we do
not have to have units or numbers
okay so what are we going to do with the
ball what we're going to measure okay
and again we don't need numbers all we
need to know is that one stick is longer
than the other okay you can see that the
distance
between the green ball the surface of
the green ball and the red uh edge there
is longer than the one on the inside
edge okay which is the blue one there or
uh yeah a bluish one
um
and so what happens let's move the ball
okay we're gonna move the ball now okay
there it is
so
has the distance changed and we're going
to hold the plane fixed right we're
going to hold that
axis
we're going to hold it fixed and the
question is has the distance changed
from where it was before
okay
and we're gonna move it some more just
so that you get the hang of it okay here
we're gonna move it to the other side if
i can get this thing in there there it
is okay has the distance change is the
distance changing from the ball to the
edges of the this plane okay
okay and i'm saying that the distance
changes the separation between the ball
and each one of those edges of that
plane is changing
from from a conceptual point of view i
think you understand
that uh
[Music]
we don't have a congruent
transformation as mr whale would say
the distances are changing okay and so
something is happening here now if that
plane
assuming right rotate it together with
the ball the distance would remain
but if you fix the uh that plane
and just move the ball the distances are
changing
okay so i want you to understand that
let's do it with a pole so that we can
get into the uh the habit of
understanding
okay here's here's uh the pole okay so
we have the the ball we we're going to
look at the distances the separation
between the surface of the ball and each
one of the edges of that barber pole
okay
and we're going to move the ball now
okay
and has the distance changed with
respect to the edges of that pole and
the answer is yes i think i think
people would agree with me that looks
like the distances are changing
and here
again moves to the other side okay
hopefully you can see that the distances
are changing you don't have to follow me
you can do this at home
uh in the presence of a rotavist always
you know it's a dangerous experiment
okay and you can figure out yeah you can
do it with a string you know you can tie
a string around a pole find out if the
distance changes okay if the string gets
shorter of longer like if you tape it to
the edge of the barber pole
okay so
uh the distance changes if you use 2d or
3d
okay that's that's the point i'm trying
to make there
let's do it with respect to the 1d now
here's the 1d
that's what it looks like
so has the distance changed with respect
to the 1d
the issue is that
the 1d we cannot illustrate it so it's
not that i'm being funny here it's that
i have nothing to show you
i cannot illustrate the 1d for you
okay
that's the problem
and so
when they when they put a 1d
artificially in the religion of
mathematics
they are sticking a physical object in
there they're insinuating that stick is
a
1d stick right is a physical object and
they're going to be establishing
distances with respect to that so-called
axis
that's what they call it
and so yeah you cannot
even imagine the twirling the rotating
the spinning
of the axis itself because it's one
dimensional
what's there to spin you don't even have
an object that's what the one that d
looks like
if you're going to talk about spin you
had better use at least a 2d
more likely a 3d object you have to
stick an axis that has some length width
and height
inside the earth inside or through the
earth and through the the moon in order
to talk about spin and it better stand
still in the case of the moon
i'm sorry in the case of the earth and
it better move together with the surface
of the moon in the case of the moon
now you might say there's another twist
here okay and let's go with that one and
you might say well bill uh what if i use
the edge
of the plane
okay there you have your one dimensional
your your one dimension
okay so you're going to use the edge
what's the problem here you can say the
edge is always one-dimensional
well is it
how
thick is your edge
where are you going to take the reading
it will right at the very edge
of the edge
well uh are you gonna use the
mathematical point
the location
the uh dot that is two
pre-illustrated for me illustrate the
edge without the
without the uh
elevated square
rectangle there that's what you got to
do
if you can't illustrate the edge all by
itself then you don't know what you're
talking about
because all you're saying is you're
trying to get away with the edge but you
can't tell me how thick how wide that
edge is
so the what is the problem the problem
is that all these people
have been using the word axis
which is has nothing to do with physics
has to do with a what they call a
mathematical object i guess that's
that's how they would describe it or
define it and what they're doing is
cheating they're doing is cheating
because what's happening
what they're doing is saying they never
worried about rotating the axis itself
so they say we just check distance
between the axis
and the ball that's going around
and of course since the axis is one
dimensional has no physicality
whatsoever because it's a concept it's
even worse than that it's a bunch of
zero dimensional points one stacked on
top of each other and so we have no idea
what this axis is
okay because you can't draw it you can't
use it as a physical object you cannot
say it belongs to physics and what they
do is they they hold it steady and they
say we just got to change your
position as they call it with respect to
the axis and so to them it doesn't make
any
difference if the axis rotates or not
because it's one-dimensional
but you can't do that in physics when
you use
2d if you want to do it with 2d like i
did here just for the purposes of
illustration or with a 3d actual object
if you're going to
talk about spin you're talking about a
physical
uh word word that belongs to physics
doesn't belong to
mathematics okay at all and if you're
gonna spin
uh and talk about spanning you're gonna
define it you better define it with
respect to a fixed axis if the axis
moves with you and the the definition of
spin is changing
uh
distances change in separations
well you won't have any separate any
change in separations if the stick moves
together with a surface if they both
rotate at the same time
so you yes we need to know whether the
axis spins or not
okay and we can't use the axis of
mathematics for two reasons one because
it's not an object
second we we cannot illustrate it
doesn't belong to physics at all
okay and so that's the problem with the
axis so yeah spin
you spin if your axis stands still
is is uh fixed
and the surface spins with respect
to that axis if like in the case of the
moon
the axis spins together with the moon
you don't have spin
okay
and uh
all you have from the moon really is
what is called an orbit meaning the moon
goes around the earth it also goes
around the um
fixed axis
of the earth okay
but it's not changing its location
assuming we're a perfect circle right
it's not changing its location
with respect to the center of that of
that axis of the earth
okay so that's the explanation of axis
two more issues people brought up when
phil says
he says what color is the sun some say
it's orange or red or yellow i say it's
white who's right
okay
the way we do it in science again to me
by the way it looks orange
that one there i don't know maybe
yellowish okay
no the way we do it in science is uh the
first thing you do okay this is the
first thing you have to do to visualize
color you close your eyes
okay
you close your eyes
now you you're gonna be able to see
color okay
and you say well how can i see color i
don't see everything's dark in here like
dark matter and black holes and you know
all this good stuff space and so on
now the way you see color is you define
um the frequency
of a color
arbitrarily let's say uh i don't know um
610 nanometers for red
so you have a nanometer or 6100
angstroms there right
you have a
frequency
and or a wavelength you can use that as
well and you use that and you say
red is defined as 600 or 610 whichever
number you choose it's whatever number
you you want that's fine you call that
red you call a number another number
yellow another one white and etcetera
and once you get those frequencies okay
or those wavelength
that's the one you're going to use and
so the sun is either red white or blue
or whatever
according to uh the wavelength that it
it has that's it
so it's uh it's by definition
it doesn't have anything to do with your
eyesight okay
okay and final issue fellow says
it says an astronaut uh screw fell off
the screw fell
as normal with gravity how come
is the screw from uh too small for zero
gravity in the space shuttle
and i don't know if he's watching the
this astronaut who played a joke on
people out there and he showed gravity
inside the space uh and he had the uh
the um uh hammer floating in the air
but the card fell
and i guess that's more or less where
this guy saw it she said the screw fell
down
maybe maybe he saw this fella
[Laughter]
okay okay so i don't know where you
found that the bolt or screw fell down
in grab in zero gravity uh maybe he had
too much to drink you know it happens to
me too when i drink too much uh a lot of
things start floating around especially
you know pink elephants
okay uh let's go with this gentleman his
name is victor toth
and uh in order to analyze him we have
to go back 5 000 years yeah that's where
we have to start
and why do we have to go back 5 000
years well here it is uh we have this uh
god
and he was uh
taught i guess that's how you pronounce
it thought thought
and he was the god of science the god of
math
yeah
and that's when they started doing i
don't know if that's where they started
because sumerians probably beat them by
a mile but this was a good place to
start for um
all kinds of
uh
mathematics uh remember geometry is
measurement of the land they constructed
buildings especially the pyramids etc
and so this is where you know uh
mathematics was uh fine-tuned okay they
kept fine-tuning it from uh millennia to
melania okay that's what happened
okay and
it looks like uh 5 000 years later we
have this gentleman and he resuscitated
he came um i think it's the the same god
somehow came alive again his name is
victor toth okay
and he claims he's a part-time physicist
okay
good and he writes profusely again on
what is it
quora question and answer site and this
is what he says in one of his
articles he says i am mostly self-taught
i won or finished near the top in
several national math championships
championships in hungary
yeah but the issue is um
the fact that he got a gold medal you
know at the olympics
you gotta or you know does that mean he
because he won a beauty contest that's
that's why he's a scientist or a
physicist you know he's talking about
math here okay and the question is
whether math is physics and physics is
math and
he goes further he says physics the
science of tangible measurable things
and that's going to be funny that he
mentions that because you know what do
you mean tangible and measurable things
i mean he's going to be talking about
dark matter
which is neither tangible or measurable
itself he can measure the maybe the
stars around the galaxy certainly he
cannot measure the dark matter
he can and certainly it's not tangible
and certainly you cannot measure or
top uh touch uh a black hole a
singularity of a black hole or or even
the event horizon so what does it mean
that physics is the science of tangible
measurable things and maybe that's why
he's a part-time physicist he's already
got it wrong from the start maybe you
know
any ways he says learning modern physics
is hard i'm still struggling with many
concepts
yeah i totally agree with him i think he
he's struggling with many concepts and
we're gonna see that today
but he gives us a recommendation to
people who like him are mostly
self-taught and he says don't try to
rewrite improve or replace a theory just
because you haven't made the effort to
understand it thoroughly
okay that's i think a good advice and
as my example shows meaning self-taught
right
the academic establishment won't reject
you just because you are an outsider
what you do has to make sense
it's interesting that he says that um
maybe the issue here is that because
he agrees with the establishment they
haven't kicked him out even though he
doesn't have a degree he's self-taught
that means he doesn't have a degree
which is very very important in
mathematics and so he's got to
downplay you know the the fact that he's
self-taught but at the same time he says
look if you're an outsider
don't go in there and start kicking you
know the bucket the the trash cans and
everything and saying you guys are all
wrong and he says try to understand the
theory so essentially what he's saying
is that because he agreed with
everything the establishment proposes
then he's accepted into the club
and and that way it's easy no no
different i mean imagine if if i go into
let me put this over here
imagine if uh if if i go to the uh
catholic church you know to the vatican
and say oh i believe in god and you know
uh and i pray every day and you know i
love the virgin and all that's good
stuff
and i believe in angels and jesus and
you know the whole works
and they're gonna accept and say come
here as my son you know they're gonna
accept me but if i go in there and say
look you guys are all crazy you know
there is no god forget the virgin and
all that
fancy stuff
well i don't think they're going to
accept me
and so this guy is not telling us
anything new in that sense you know what
is he saying
he's just saying that he bowed down to
the establishment he accepts the
establishment and that's why they
accepted him
yeah no kid i mean
that's not fair
okay
but he says i desperately hope that in
another article that i don't spread
falsehoods as a result of being unaware
of my own ignorance
we hope so too okay
okay so that's the starting point uh how
much does uh
mr thoth know about
uh physics i mean he says he's a
part-time physicist
i hope so you know i mean it doesn't
matter if you studied or not and that's
not important important is what he says
okay
and so you know i checked a couple of
his articles i didn't check them all i
mean he's got a lot he's got like 9 000
articles he's quite popular there okay
and i checked the series of articles
that are interest to me
okay and one of them was electricity
what is the nature of electricity
and uh i don't find them there you know
uh here's what is electricity and
you see all these questions that people
post in quora and you would think that
after 9 000
plus
articles that he wrote most of them on
so-called physics-related subjects you
would think that at least he would have
answered one or two of these
and i haven't found him maybe maybe he's
there maybe i'm you know uh overlooking
something but i haven't found him tell
me the
uh the nature
of electricity
okay and so
what can i say
i didn't find it and maybe you guys are
better than me at this and can look it
up but i was not able to find it and the
same
thing happened with magnetism okay he
hasn't answered a single
article or question
related to the nature what is
magnetism how does a magnet attract
another i don't see them there
and you would think that this is like
kindergarten stuff that you know people
want to know these things and
one of the first questions you want to
answer is this is what electricity is
this is what magnetism is
this is how it's done this is that
invisible world in there this is how a
magnet attracts another
i mean this is kindergarten stuff we
learned this in the first week of
physics
and this guy can't give us
you know a an explanation i mean i don't
see him there at least
maybe i missed an article maybe i don't
know uh anyone can is willing to correct
me i'm willing to apologize if if it was
me that missed the article that says
this is what a magnet what
um what magnetism is and how a magnet
attracts another this is what
electricity is right i need to know that
and uh
i don't see them there and so you know
it to me it was strange that he writes
over 9 000 articles and he didn't
address those two issues
that's just me okay
and um here we have him on light is
light made up of photons the only one
really i could find maybe he's got a
couple more i don't know but uh
but i looked at it and said okay let's
see what he says about light okay does
he know what light is
and essentially came up with this
question and says yes what we call light
is a is the visible part of the
electromagnetic spectrum waves radiation
rays those are the words to use
and yeah the problem is there is no
physical object called waves there is no
physical object called radiation and
there's no physical object called rays
so to say that light
is
a wave light is radiation light is a ray
he's saying light is a concept all these
are concept none of these are physical
objects stand-alone physical objects
okay so um yeah he can't tell me what
light is at least in that sentence okay
it's not there
and he says light is electromagnetic
radiation again no such thing as
radiation photons are the quanta
of electromagnetic waves in the quantum
theory okay photons what are photons
light therefore consists of photons okay
so you go down the rabbit hole and you
look for the photon and photon says a
type of elementary particle packet of
energy those are some of the things
you'll find out there and you get go
deeper into the rabbit hole and it says
particle what is a particle right
probability amplitude wave function
so when you get down to the you know to
the end of the onion when you keep
peeling peeling peeling you find nothing
there
so yeah we don't know what light is
and uh here's an analogy for
what he's saying there okay i take this
as an analogy
uh klingon comes over and asks what is a
cat
and so uh
mr talk here says a cat is an animal
okay what is an animal i mean he comes
from another planet right please have
pity on him
and he said and uh thoth would answer
it's an animal is all love
okay what is love
it's an equation numbers and variables
and so the klingon says okay so a cat is
ultimately a bunch of numbers
and he said well you have to go to
college to really understand it okay
and those are the type of answers these
people do they always leave you hanging
in the air because they never answer the
question that's the point okay so if
like mr toth says here light is made of
photons and then photons turns out that
are made of concepts of love
of uh information or who knows when if
it's made out of concepts well what is
light then light is nothing it's a
concept
okay uh i mean
not the notion of light but i mean what
is it made of i mean here you you talk
about uh cases like you know the uh
what is it the photoelectric effect
and
they talk about einstein talked about
this he got into noble for that that
the electron bead
uh is kicked out of its you know out of
its atom by a photon
that has the right energy blah blah blah
okay so you have a little bead known as
a photon hitting a little bead
known as the electron very good shot by
the way you can imagine that photon just
hitting that electron which nobody can
find around the
proton right it happens to hit it
and kick it out and now you have running
current
and so looks like the photon
according to mr einstein at least is
something physical
okay because you have this bead hitting
another bead
and now when you look it up it says no
it's a wave function
okay
so what a hit so what hit the electron
which is another wave function
okay so we have more wave functions here
in all of these
okay
give me a second here
wave function on top of wave function
okay so uh where do we go from this well
he ends up saying uh freaking photons
anyways you know freaking throw them
away especially forget photons as
miniature cannonballs
so he's saying they're not beads okay
that's what he's saying what undoubtedly
does exist meaning he's saying a photon
doesn't exist
is the electromagnetic field
where field oh field every time i hear
feel that tremble you know
and this field interacts with other
fields
fields interacting with fields
love interacting with love energy with
energy
time with time seconds with minutes i
guess okay exchanging energy and
momentum so they exchange
more concepts okay
is there an object called energy please
draw it i want to see it what does it
look like okay the electromagnetic field
is a quantum field
and we call these quantum
photons but what we actually observe
eyes you know
is the electromagnetic field itself
i do envy his great vision uh he is able
to see fields i haven't i haven't i
guess drank enough
you look a field another rabbit hole a
quantity a quantity a number
numbers
represented by a number okay
that has a value for each point in space
and time
that's what he's talking about
and he says he can observe it you can
see it
and he says that's what really a photon
is a field
so no matter whether you go with the
wave function or where the field you end
up with absolutely nothing
and yeah i can see why he said at the
beginning that he has trouble
understanding
you know physical concepts yeah i agree
okay and uh here he continues is what is
gravity
and he said gravity is a tensor field
okay that couples universally and
minimally to all other fields
okay and so he clarifies that a 10
series determines how field behaves okay
and couples means does not distinguish
between various forms of stuff and
universally means the tensorflow plays a
role in forming products and calculating
volume blah blah
he didn't
define the word field which is the one
we were waiting for we don't know what a
field is that's the one he had to define
so we had to look it up and it says
um well you know when you look up the
word field it's just a bunch of numbers
i just showed and
he ends up his
his article saying it may take many more
iterations before we happen upon the
real answer
so he doesn't know what gravity is
after all that he says all this he he i
think he makes money because sends
people to patreon and uh so he gets
donations
and he can't tell him what a gravity is
he says you gotta wait 100 what 400 more
years
we waited since galileo newton you know
17th century
scientific revolution
and now we've got to wait another 400
years maybe we'll find out what gravity
is you know someday you know
and again this is like the klingon
asking about the cat he said what is a
cat
and uh so
he says a cat is an animal that eats
fish meows gets sick sleeps has kitties
and poops okay so he defines each one of
these he gives them an idea let us eat
to pig out lets me out to make noises to
sleep to close your eyes great okay but
we want to know what the word animal
means
and so he said what's a bunch of
particles and you know when you look at
particles you find out that particles
are really numbers or maybe fields and
you're back to square one
and then he adds at the end he said it
may take many more years before we find
out what an animal is
so
that is the situation folks this is how
mathematical physics explains everything
so we we are very much familiar with all
their so-called explanations of things
up there why
do we have this situation because they
never define the words especially the
word object the word thing you can't do
physics without a thing
and no mathematician ever discovered
that from the days of the greeks and
before although it is even gawking in
the rest of them today not one of them
ever discovered how important the word
object is to
explain a mechanism to provide a
physical interpretation what they do is
they use concepts
they move concepts around mathematical
concepts and they think they're juggling
balls you know when they're all they're
doing is
uh in their dreams they're moving
concepts around
okay but uh what's the issue today well
we've been uh we've been dealing with
dark matter lately and mr todd thoth has
something to say about dark matter okay
in fact he's quite heavily involved in
dark matter and that's why i chose him
for the lecture today
and again he's just the poster boy
but he represents
a whole army of people out there that do
the same thing okay and he is a
prominent
individual in the sense that he um he's
in quora he's
uh educating you can say or
mis-educating a new generation of people
who read borah who go in there and ask
questions he answers them okay
and so what does mr toth have to say
about dark matter and here it is
and he starts in one article i think
this was in forbes i'm not sure now
and some time ago i think a couple years
ago and he says the missing matter is
called dark matter there you see the
little chart that's not his by the way i
pulled that other somewhere other place
the remaining stuff with negative
pressure is called dark energy
so you can see dark energy is what 73 of
the ignorance we have of the universe
and dark matter is only 23 of the
ignorance that's 96
of the ignorance that not we but the
mathematicians mathematicians have of
the universe uh
the rest is what we can see maybe even
called touch right
and uh that's that small percentage
there that four percent remaining there
okay
okay so that's where he starts but he
said
oh this is pretty solid
rigorous mathematics
so what does mathematics have to do with
things
okay we're talking about things here he
says it's rigorous because we have it
mathematically down pat
and then he ends up
says yet at the same time we have not
the faintest clue as to what these dark
thingies really are
what a lesson they have no clue what
their they have but it's been proven
with mathematics and so yeah you have
the whole establishment out there they
believe in dark matter they believe in
the reality of dark matter
and why because they've proven it
mathematically to exist now they tell
the astronomer to look through his
telescope and go look for it and they
ask the guy at the at cern slack and
fermi lab to go out there and smash
particles to see if he can produce
dark matter what
particles
so we do know what
dark matter is they're particles
why did i think of that yeah they're
particles they're ultra heavy particles
that these people sprinkle around the
outside of a galaxy to make the
equations come out right that mimic
the rotation of a galaxy
and so there's sprinkling all these
goodies these kilograms
they're sprinkling all these kilograms
preferentially where they need them for
the equation to come out right that
describes the rotation of a galaxy
so we do know what dark matter is
they're little tiny particles that we
can't see
and they're very ultra heavy why they
call them darkest is the mystery
it's a mystery because as i showed the
other day you can see right through them
okay you can see right through the
dark uh matter halo disc that spreads
out way beyond
a galaxy okay the halo that's around the
galaxy you can see right through then
see stars in the background so the word
dark is not really the proper
adjective maybe they should call it
invisible or maybe translucent or
transparent matter that would probably
be better you know
so uh what would they tell the guy at
the accelerator look for dark matter oh
i can find that easily i know i'm sorry
look for
transparent matter oh i have trouble
with that one
i don't know how i'm going to look for
that
okay
and here he says uh
he gives a an idea here he says dark
matter maybe wimps
okay what are whims weakly interacting
massive particles okay
um
particles what are what particles fields
what are fields nothing okay we got that
okay but he continues says this is
important keep an eye on this one he
says i believe that we need to find ways
to you know actually detect these dark
thingies before we can say anything
definite about their
nature
ah
a slight
[Music]
trying to say something here i don't
know maybe maybe i'm wrong right yes
let's find out and then there is the
option that perhaps these dark thingies
do not even exist
this is blasphemy
they are mirages of sorts because we are
doing the math using the wrong theory of
gravity
what is mr thoth getting into here what
is he talking about
uh what am i supposed to understand from
this
well i'll tell you what it's about
i'll tell you well my my personal
impression of this my this is my take on
this okay
my impression is that
mr thoth like mrs sabine hassenfelder we
talked about the other d and like mr
milgram uh um
i can't remember his name
uh jewish vowel who came up with monde
the modified newtonian dynamics okay
and
all these people they don't really
believe in dark matter
okay and i think mr toth is there as
well okay he half believed but he kind
of doesn't believe because after 40
years we can't see it out there in the
sky it's translucent it's heavily
heavily
heavy
meaning meaning that it's ad hoc let's
put in there by hand
remember
show you well i'm going to get into that
in a second here but
uh
they don't really believe
that there's this dark matter
and so what do they believe in
well what's the alternative okay it's
interesting for what i'm going to talk
about later which is the pioneer
pros because the exact opposite in the
case of the pioneer pros there he
believes the opposite okay so here we go
uh he he wrote on a couple articles okay
and what is he talking about well he's
proposing new equations
for
um
for how how um gravity works so he's
trying to modify just like mr milgram
did with monde and like miss hassan
felder is trying to do with her group in
a dark matter group here in germany and
what they do is they they're saying that
the equations need modifications
and in the case of uh milgram it was ma
monde and here they call it mod it's the
modified uh gravity okay that's what
they call it okay here are two papers on
this okay you can look him up
okay so what do we have well uh
he i think he's an atheist
or becoming an atheist or about to
become one or
uh maybe he's an agnostic i'm not sure
what the
uh
right qualifier is of dark matter
i don't think he believes much in dark
matter he's trying to find another
solution the solution is an equation
okay so they're trying to modify
uh gravity okay
and in a strange way
he is absolutely correct
okay so let's continue here
that's the funny part here we have the
dark matter conundrum okay that i talked
about the other day okay you can look it
up in the previous videos i'm just going
to run quickly through this what's the
issue the issue is that you have this
the final equation i'm not going to go
through the whole
derivation here uh just look at the v
for velocity forget about the squared
we're not interested in that we're
looking at this qualitatively okay so we
have velocity and it's equal to gm
uh gravitational constant big mass over
uh little r i made it big why because
the issue is that the farther a star is
from the center of its galaxy the slower
it should go
and why is that the case because if you
increase r you can see what happens to v
okay v is going to go down the velocity
of that star has to go down okay so if
you increase the distance between the
star in the center of the galaxy the
bigger you make r the bigger you make
that distance
the
smaller will be your v
but that's not what we observe when they
put their telescopes out there and they
look at all these galaxies what they see
is that the stars on the outside go
faster
or at the same speed or faster right
to compensate for that
they created this frankenstein monster
known as dark matter
a big mass
that they
sprinkle preferentially on the outside
of a galaxy and they say oh
with this mass now we can explain why
the galaxy rotates the way it does okay
because that's all we needed that mass
there to keep the first the star from
flying away
we need to keep it there you know
because the
star flies away
you know from the galaxy the galaxy
would be throwing all these stars around
you know like you coming out of a
merry-go-round that's going at 100 miles
per hour okay
spinning
right already okay so they created this
dark matter thing and it has to be very
big to compensate for the r in order for
the little v not to get smaller for the
little v to get bigger if anything okay
so that's the issue what's the problem
well you can see that halo there around
the galaxy and that's the dark matter
that's the one they can't see
is it dark
well no it ain't it's not uh dark and
i'll tell you why because see
take a look at that
good look and here goes
you can see the stars right through the
halo like if the halo weren't there
that's the issue
so if you can see right through the halo
of a galaxy well we shouldn't call it
dark matter because if it were dark we
would see a veil there you know we
wouldn't see those stars that's not the
case or galaxies no we see right through
the halo
as if it weren't there at all and this
is what makes some people like i think
mr toss for sure uh
other people
that maybe dark matter is a figment of
our imagination maybe it's not real okay
that's the issue
okay so uh okay they created this
monster called dark matter
and now they told the astronomers go
look for it and they tell the people
that the accelerator is the same thing
go look for it
have something to do uh earn your pay
now these people are all busy receiving
funds from you because most of it is
public money and what are they doing
they're looking for dark matter they're
looking for ghosts and angels go look
for a ghost go look for an angel and say
what does it look like it's transparent
okay i'll come back with it
that's where we're at
okay and how do we explain this in
science in physics how do we explain
this dark matter nonsense okay that the
mathematicians created this monster okay
we start here and we say that all atoms
in the universe are physically
interconnected and i said physically
interconnected okay they're connected
okay we're not going to go into the
details we're just going to say they're
physically connected right now think of
them as strings as uh little uh threads
whatever you want to call it okay so
unlike mathematical physics that deals
with discrete particles and they cannot
explain specifically the force of pull
okay
then um
which we can under the uh
rope model as i call it the rope
hypothesis all atoms being
interconnected well we can explain it
with uh we can explain pull because
there is a physical connection there is
no actual action at a distance okay it's
just that we can't see or touch the
mediators and that's different
than saying that there is nothing there
and they say well you can't see or touch
it it's not there it doesn't exist it's
not an object and that's because they've
always had the wrong definition an
irrational definition of the word object
and of the word exist
and so we have to settle the language we
need to know what
we mean by object by thing and we need
to know what we mean by exist
what is an object that which has shape
not that which you can see or touch you
can't see or touch the table that's on
the other side of the universe see and
touch require two objects
and um
besides it's uh involves motion and
motion and objects have to be have to be
defined before motion okay so there's
many arguments against the c-touch
criterion that the mathematicians have
used now for what since at least since
the days of the greeks okay that's what
they use that's why they go to the lab
because they
expect to see and touch
and you won't see or touch the mediators
of mother nature here's a my famous test
okay
take a pencil always in the presence of
a relativist okay and you let go of it
and it falls down okay
do you see anything in contact with a
pen or a pencil from above or below
no you don't
and yet this one doesn't
never falls to the ceiling it always
falls to the floor
always falls to the earth and you say
well it's impossible we can't figure it
out
you can't figure it out
there's only two objects the pencil and
the earth
two objects
you have only two objects the moon and
the earth you have only two objects the
sun and jupiter
and you can't figure it out it's so
difficult
well it's difficult because you haven't
seen
the mediators why because the mediators
are unseeable untouchable they're
intangible invisible that's why not
because they're not there an object is
that which has shape not that which you
can see or touch that's where we start
and uh and so yeah that's that's the
starting point for
why
we put these strings there and what
we're saying is there is no action at a
distance it's mathematics that does
magic by doing action at a distance
without mediators
that's why they're doing all their uh
mechanisms irrationally
nobody can imagine whatever the
mathematicians talk about because
immediately they're going to introduce
concepts the field
energy mass time we don't need any of
that garbage you can sweep all those
words out of the dictionary we don't
need them in physics and or in science
okay so how do we do it if all atoms are
physically interconnected
it's a piece of cake this is baby stuff
it's for kindergarteners this dark
matter thingy the gravitate the
uh
galaxy rotation problem it's for babies
we don't we don't even
you don't even have to spend two bits of
brain on this thing okay here it is okay
all uh we start saying that all stars
are physically connected because all
atoms are physically connected and that
also explains why they all tend towards
the center of a galaxy and why the
rotation of the galaxy keeps them at bay
that's why a galaxy is shaped more or
less like it's shaped
what do we do with this next well we go
in here and we put the uh thing on top
of a galaxy that is rotating so all the
stars in a galaxy are physically
connected okay they're connected by the
electromagnetic ropes and those are the
ones that mediate gravity as well so we
have the grand unified theory okay
and um so from here where do we go okay
well here we have
uh on top of that we're going to put the
magnetic field of the galaxy which these
people never place they talk about it
but they never use it okay here it is
and uh magnetic field of a galaxy
extends way beyond the galaxy way far
out okay and it's powerful what is the
magnetic field it's threads sweeping
down
okay
like in the sun okay they go out one
pole and come out and come into the
other pole okay that's what it is these
are threads that are swinging around a
star in this case around a galaxy also
around the earth okay so we're talking
about threads physical threads that are
coming down okay
going through uh the center of whatever
object in this case the galaxy
and
you'll hear about
jets because they say there's a black
hole in the center of every galaxy no no
these people are confusing the magnetic
field
we'll call it that okay for brevity and
coming out of the in this case the north
pole of the galaxy and entering the
south pole that's what we're talking
about when they talk about jets okay
there are no jets
okay and uh yeah one thing that you can
visualize is that if you have three of
these galaxies okay
and here i just put three of them
they're magnetic fields that extend
gazillions of miles you know from from
the object uh could very well um
you know uh affect one another in other
words they're
interacting with one another and of
course where those magnetic fields
interact uh we can see some very fancy
stuff among them you know the so-called
black hole and i've talked about that in
the past i'm not going to deal with it
right now i just want to show that you
know magnetic fields can interact
because we're not talking about concepts
we're talking about physical objects
what are those physical objects they are
threads
threads of the rope
the bottom line or the
ultimate
underlying hypothesis is that there's a
single thread
in the entire universe just a single
closed blue thread which turns into
everything that is out there that all
the matter that exists in the universe
and uh this thread turns into the rope
which is con which connects any two
atoms uh torsion of which is what we
call light and it goes from one atom to
another okay and the atoms are made of
the same thread so everything in the
universe is interconnected not only
interconnected but everything in the
universe is made
of the same thread
of one thread
a
closed loop thread and there could be
another
universe
another
body of matter
made of another thread
we'll call it a parallel universe
because it's probably the right concept
meaning that the space
is the same for all of us but the matter
is not
none of those atoms in that universe are
connected to any
of the atoms of our universe
and a funny thing about that if these
two universe were to cross each other we
can probably crash against one of their
atoms adam against adam but we would not
see him because we don't have a
connection the rope connection from that
atom to our atom we have no
connection
to see
these atoms from our point of view in
other words uh the reason you see the
andromeda galaxy at night is because
every atom in the andromeda galaxy
every single one of them is connected to
the atoms of your eyes otherwise we
would not see the torsions
moving along those existing mediators
okay that's the story okay let's move on
to another issue and that's that
mr talk deals with dealt with uh the
pioneer anomaly uh problem and you had
pioneer 10 you had pioneer 11
and they were
sent out in the 70s
early 70s and they eventually
left the solar system okay
and
sometime about 20 years after they sent
them out a little over that
they realized that you know they took
some data and they said hey you know
the probes are not where they're
supposed to be they're supposed to be
farther out into space
and
one of our both of them were like 300
000 kilometers
closer to the sun than they should be
and that's the distance from the earth
to the moon roughly
and
that's not a big distance in the uh uh
you know context of the universe
but it was a measurable distance they
said this this probe should be farther
out okay and so one fellow who was in
charge of the program anderson he wrote
a paper and he said you know we we
looked at everything and we can't figure
it out why
that thing is not farther out where it
should be where it was calculated to be
why it's 300 000 or so kilometers closer
to the sun
something is pulling it back or it was
kind of decelerating towards the sun it
wasn't accelerating at the speed you
know
at the rate it should have been
accelerating that was the issue
and so one guy name is murphy he wrote a
paper okay
and he said the following he says
anderson and have recently modeled the
acceleration acting on pioneer 10 11
ulysses galileo spacecraft they find an
anomalous
excess acceleration of
directed towards the sun so there was a
deceleration in other words towards the
sun right it was the probe was not
running away fast enough they have ruled
out excess gravitational forces due to
the galaxy and unidentified plant
planetesimals errors in the orbital
rotational parameters of the earth
spacecraft gas leaks and heirs in
planetary ephemeris as explanations for
the acceleration in addition the authors
rule out this is an important one
radiation pressure from thermal
radiation generated by the spacecraft
radioisotope thermoelectric generators
in other words rtgs okay
and so uh they couldn't figure it out
and they said uh but the important one
is they ruled out this uh thermal
radiation okay the heat
that the probe was apparently uh
spitting out
preferentially in one direction
and so what uh
this all said says well you know uh the
assumption was wrong the assumption was
that
the
this heat was being
spit out
um
isotopically in other words it was um
uniformly spread out
and this file was arguing that no it was
really in one direction and that
direction happened to be the direction
in which it was traveling and so that
uh served as a
you know kind of like a damper on on
speed okay that's more or less what this
fall was saying and that's the idea that
these uh folks who took over the
investigation of that problem uh
concluded it was uh like a foregone
conclusion that's what they were trying
to prove and turns out that's what they
proved and this is uh follow he's
russian name is turischev and you can
see uh tot's name right next to his okay
and they published this article in 2012
about uh
14 years after the problem was
discovered and so what did they find
well they say the anomalous acceleration
of the pioneer 10 and 11 spacecraft is
due to what to the recall force
associated with anisotropic emission of
thermal radiation of off the vehicles
okay we constructed comprehensive finite
element thermal model of two
spacecraft then we numerically solve
thermally thermal conduction and
radiation equations using the actual
flight telemetry as boundary conditions
so they went in there and essentially
you know this this is the
notion that they had that this probe was
out there spinning in one direction
direction of travel and because of that
uh that heat it was uh dissipating that
slowed it down that was the notion that
they had okay and that's what they
published in their physical review
letters there yeah
okay so this is where they uh started
this is how they concluded they
essentially
had already a theory because the theory
came from 1998 and these guys published
2012 14 years later and they say oh by
the way we approved that theory that's
essentially what it was how did they
prove it they went in there and looked
for data they uh crunched data you know
for
several years and then they came out
with their conclusions
okay
so uh this is uh where it stands because
you know some people criticized that
they said well you know it's more or
less the case of the
uh fox guarding the chicken coop you
know because these guys were the ones
who ran the project and it's more or
less like guys who investigated the
solution to the problem they said we
found it
yeah okay maybe you know it could be
some people criticize them here was one
guy you know paul ten boom
nice uh name you know for a group ten
boom
and he says this paper discusses the
likelihood of whether the pioneer
anomaly is due to mundane systematic
errors effects or indicative of new or
unreached unappreciated physics
see the again the issue here was whether
there was new physics whether we had to
change the gravitation equation
and it turns out that uh in this case
uh thoth mr toss he went in there and he
uh he said look in this case uh we're
gonna say that uh the equation is
correct what's wrong is the heat inside
the the probes but in the case of dark
matter he's going he's getting away from
dark matter and choosing the equation so
it's it's interesting that he had that
change of heart that you could say or
change of tactic or theo
strategy
and he said the the main aim of this
paper is to argue that recent
publications suggesting that the anomaly
is previously overlooked thermal recall
forces which is in stark contrast to the
earlier consensus 98 to 10 are open to
questioning okay
so um
you know some people even to today there
was a paper in 2020 that also criticized
this uh
um
at least one that i read that criticized
the
pioneer anomaly
conclusion okay and again a lot of
people say there's a new physics going
on
and uh
i agree i'm gonna show that
okay yeah there is new physics that
these people are not aware of okay
okay um
so
uh
what happened was you had the planetary
society they had to give these people
money funds to do the research and
that's what they did and here you have
it it says the only way to solve this
mystery was to look at much more data
than had previously been available so
they're saying that the anderson group
the original group well they didn't have
enough data and they didn't really do
the research properly you know
scientifically and this guy turism he
came in there he pulled all that state
out that was about to be canned by the
way so he saved it just in time and they
needed some money and so uh the money
was provided by the planetary society
and it says that that is where planetary
society members stepped in a few years
ago slava turischev and his colleagues
at the jet propulsion laboratory were in
desperate need of funding okay to help
them do just that with funds supplied by
our members turish have successfully
chased down data from a number of
sources and what he said pioneers
anomaly solve case closed sweep it under
the rug
okay that's how they solve problems in
mathematics yeah they they put an end to
it they said no more discussion we
figured it out don't don't talk about it
again
how do we do it in science okay well if
all atoms in the universe are physically
interconnected we have a different
universe and especially we have a new
notion of gravity at greater distances
that's where the problem comes okay at
greatest distances we should
uh what do they call it mathematics
prediction that's what they do in
mathematics they call it predictions we
can predict
retroactively we can predict the origin
of the universe all that kind of stuff
right
the big bang uh conditions in the big
bang okay we can predict
that um
dark matter and all this stuff is gonna
behave a little differently okay why and
here you see it
this is a
notion of newtonian gravity okay it's
the notion of square of the distance and
we all learned this by wrote in high
school you know it's been proven
certified it's a done deal okay so this
is the square of the distance
what do i propose what is the
rope hypothesis propose in exchange well
here it is we propose the bird speak
we're saying that
uh
what newton uh newton's equation only is
for a certain distance that's where you
have the that triangle there but the
further out you go
uh
you know the
ropes that connect every atom in the
universe coming out of the sun this is
the sun and of course i didn't put the
planets in there uh what you have is uh
at some point they should produce that
curve okay
and we're going to see in a minute here
how that changes gravity uh right at the
edge of the solar system
okay
so let me remove this and let me show
you this one
versus the other so you can see it side
by side or up and down
okay so this is the difference between
them okay you see
the square of the this is versus the
bird's beak as i call it okay
and that comes from the assumption that
all atoms are physically interconnected
by the
uh where is it the electromagnetic rope
okay two atoms bound by
a pair of twine threads that's what what
the universe is like that's the
main unit of the universe i guess you
could say
okay so where do we go from here well
here we have it here's the burst beak
okay
and here's the sun
and there's uh that star there that's uh
alpha centauri okay and you're a star
proxima centauri in this case right and
so what do we have we have um the bird
speak going from one sun to the other
from one star to the other so if you
start at one star and you take all the
ropes that extend outwards the majority
of the ropes the overwhelming majority
of the ropes are gonna converge upon
some kind of coaxial that holds these
two stars together okay so we call that
the linear regime that's between them
and there is no gravity
no pull of ready no pull of gravity no
um
uh square of the distance gravity in the
linear region okay
so this is the notion that uh comes from
the rope hypothesis okay
that straight line there that's going to
be
the linear regime okay
okay so what's the issue now the issue
is that there is no
gravity as we feel it here on earth in
the linear
region and that's because of the
assumptions we make okay
so it's contingent on the assumption the
assumption is that all atoms in the
universe are physically interconnected
by twine pair of threads the
electromagnetic
rope
okay so uh let's look at the linear
regime and tell you what happens when an
astronaut
wants to leave the earth or in this case
the pioneer 10s and 11s okay
so here's the astronaut trying to leave
you know with the spaceship he's trying
to leave the earth
and at some point he's going to go
through these
this linear regime which is just
straight lines primarily running
straight into every atom of his ship
including himself okay and so when you
look at this you know
there you have one direction proxima and
the other one sun the sun and when your
spaceship tries to leave okay the birds
speak the end of the bird speak well
it's going to slow down
of course it's going to slow down okay
and again you have no no pull of gravity
at least from the front all you have is
just
essentially going in a straight line
even though that's not
exactly like that but you get the the
idea the idea is that the bird speak
gives you an idea of how gravity behaves
at the edge of the solar system
okay so it's a new theory for those of
you who
are not familiar with it okay and so
it's a based on new assumptions and the
assumptions is that we don't do action
at a distance in science that's religion
worse it's mathematics okay religion is
still rational to some degree i guess
you could say mathematics is all
irrational why because they are moving
concepts around
they replace objects or or better yet
they reify concepts and they treat them
they reify concepts and treat them as if
they were objects
that's the story
okay and that was just in a nutshell of
course there are many questions when you
have a new theory out there and uh
you're welcome to put them
and i'll try to answer them by next time
okay let's get on with the uh
questions that people made
hey uh comments people raised since last
time
paul says hi bill uh how would you
explain the feeling one often has when
someone is looking at them
well it depends if it's ted bundy you
may be scared i don't know
also have you ever had a very certain
intuition that strangely
rang true or even saved you from a
deadly situation
well we don't we don't do a lot of this
stuff um you know uh
what feelings people have
uh partly because you know uh there's
not much you can
uh
that everybody's that everyone's gonna
draw the same conclusions from that okay
do we have extra sensorial uh
experiences
you may have dreams you may dream that
you're gonna win the lottery and it
turns out you you did win the lottery
it turns out that a million people dream
that they're gonna win the lottery only
one guy gets it he says oh
my dream came true and that's how he
says it he says oh maybe my dream
triggered it or maybe i went to the
future and i knew about it and didn't
even know it i was unconscious of it and
you have all these situations and yet
one guy will always win the lottery many
millions of people will not win the
lottery their dreams don't come true and
so are there extra sensorial
you know uh feelings out there
you know
it's outside the bonds of physics the
only thing you can say is uh the ropes
that converge upon your your atoms of
your body from every atom in the
universe
are there influences there
well you do have gravity and light in
other words you have a certain tug there
that's one issue and the other one is
you have a certain
thumping
on every one of the atoms of your body
okay
and so that's all you can say now does
that mean that
that gives you that gives you a certain
type of mind
which is a creation of the atoms in your
brain
well that's a far stretch of the
imagination you know to say that you
know the light that hits you or the
gravity that hits your atom triggered a
certain thought
uh i don't know
i'll hold my
my opinion and i don't think so uh what
can i say
okay another fella he says that is a
wave of energy
energy energy
traveling at sea containing infinite
infinite infinite what is infinite uh
possible potential light particles in
our space and time yeah particles are
what were particles uh wave functions
something like that okay the wave of
energy the wave
we have the waves here here's the wave
okay
what's waving that's what you got to
identify don't tell me the wave no
physical object called wave but he says
the wave travels traveling at sea does
so as potential light particles again
okay outside our frame of space and time
when the wave comes to a rest whoa the
wave rests
and
by either striking an object reflecting
or absorbing off the surf off a surface
or when it is measured it converts into
light
okay uh particles containing information
so the particle contains information we
have here a wave function that waves and
it contains information
all the stuff we learned in college
when traveling at sea the light
information
does not exist
no kid
what is an object that exists it's got
to be an object and it's got to have
location we're not talking about objects
so i'm not sure how it can any of this
can exist
uh in our frame of reference containing
space distance and time it exists as a
potential in our space and time
these people have been brainwashed so
much with the language of mathematics
that is so ridiculous and it's sad to
see them because they they truly believe
in all this stuff they they repeat it
verbatim they just learn the words and
they just say oh yeah i understand this
we have the energy going in this way and
the energy contains information and then
we have the field and that's vibrating
and then time we have it it bends all
the time you know
my poor god
okay another fellow says if i throw a
pen up and nothing pulls on edge
shouldn't it just keep going up
well not if the pen oh
pencil here okay not if the pen not if
every atom of the pencil is attached to
every atom on earth
then it's
you throw it up because you gave it
force
uh equal mass times acceleration
but then uh
tension not force but because newton's
equation is about force but the real one
is tension
tension
equals uh gravitational constant g mass
one mass two divided by distance square
pulls it down
okay
you know uh what happens is you have
more and more ropes
acting independently as the um
momentum you know slows down
and at that point you have more
a certain number of ropes as that thing
comes drifting back down because again
it's closer to the earth and to the moon
then as it comes drifting down the
ropes separate the more the further down
it is the more they separate and the
closer it is to the earth the more it
separates and that's what we call
acceleration of gravity okay that's the
way it is so yeah you throw the pencil
up it had better come down if uh gravity
was working according to how mother
nature made it originally okay
okay another fellow he says
theory the fanning out of the ropes as
an object approaches say a planet okay
the gravity seems to result in torque
okay that each atom exerts on the
object's atoms okay i see where he's
going with this it might be
the case that each rope is serving as a
constraint plane on the atoms of the
object while all atomic motion is
exerting torques onto the object
so he's insinuating with this uh the
torque effect has gets higher as the
ropes angles our funnel
are fanned out
the problem here is he thinks that uh or
is suggesting i guess he is
hypothesizing or theorizing or
speculating that perhaps just perhaps
uh gravity is a function of torque
and my answer is no
um
according to the rock model okay
gravity is a function of how many row
acceleration of gravity let's say right
is a function of how many ropes are at
different locations of an object
remember weight is location specific
you have weight only a given weight for
only a given location an astronaut only
has weight for a given location
from the
let's say the center of the ear or the
center of gravity of the earth okay
he's he's at a certain location he
weighs 100 pounds okay
but if he's closer
he had better weight 200 pounds
so all he needs to do is really is you
know if he's weighs 100 pounds at a
certain distance in in the sky or maybe
20 pounds or whatever as soon as he
moves an inch closer to the earth he has
a totally different total different
weight
why because now the ropes have separated
a little bit
just by taking a a
step one inch closer to the earth his
ropes fanned out the gazillions of ropes
in his body connected to gazillions of
rope on earth they all fanned out a
little bit and now you have more ropes
and that
that number of ropes that now have
fanned out that's a measure of his
weight
okay
so no i say it's not torque okay it's
not a question of torque remember also
that in the case of the rope right
you have the uh y you know the c little
c equals frequency times wavelength why
because there you have you have the
equation of the rope there that is the
equation of a rope the only thing i can
model c equals
constant c which is the velocity of
light the only thing that can model that
frequency times wavelength is is a rope
because you have the link you know here
you have one link okay
and if you talk it more well you have
more links but each link is smaller more
links frequency smaller link wavelength
okay so only a row can imitate c equals
frequency times wavelength and so no
it's not a question i'm talking the only
issue with torque
is that it guarantees the
constancy of the velocity of light
little c 300 000 kilometers per second
okay another fellow he scares me he says
can you speak on anti-matter well
okay
so how do we do it in science well we
say
what is an object not just that which
has shape
what does exist mean well physical
presence means you have to have an
object that which has shape and an
object has to have location
set of distances with respect to all
other objects in the universe okay so we
know what object didn't exist mean
okay what does matter matter is set of
objects that exist
okay so all the objects that exist we
call that matter
you can take a subset of that and call
it matter as well okay
anti-matter well uh and what is that
anti-charge anti-mass uh anti-shape
anti-size
what is anti-matter matters matter is
matter is matter
and you call it anti-matter and
anti-matter i guess is
matter
because they say what's matter well what
kind of matter well it's such matter
that has such properties that when it
hits matter it turns into
empty space
nothing how did it do explain the
process
explain the mechanism don't tell me that
you did math and from
100 you ended up with zero we don't care
about that what we want to know is
explain the mechanism of how
a particle i guess
you have two balls okay
two little balls okay
one is matter and the other one's
anti-matter great no problem
uh you want to give them positive charge
a negative charge go ahead you want to
give them
positive mass negative mass no problem
they clash or they touch or whatever and
they turn into zip
explain the process explain the
mechanism
of disintegration
that's what i want of how
something which is three-dimensional has
length width and height
turns into zero dimensional nothing
i need i need the formula i need
i want to become rich you know i want i
want the formula give me give me the
mechanism
you can go to god's garage
and see if you can find it there no
without a mechanism we have nothing
for them to do a little bit of math and
say we have positive charge here
negative charge there or positive mass
negative mass and turned into no mass or
no charge or whatever it's garbage
that's nonsense that's mathematics and
again if mathematics stays within
mathematics we have no problem with it i
mean i love mathematics i do a lot of
mathematics myself
but uh when you bring mathematics into
physics now that's where we run into
trouble when we have mathematical
physics now we're in trouble
because math has nothing at all to do
with physics okay math is math physician
is physics
never the twins shall meet
okay another fellow talks about dark
matter and he says dark matter and dark
energy are ponzi schemes
yeah
okay politics here okay to rake in gray
uh grant money researching stuff that
doesn't really exist okay researching
stuff sorry
general relativity is missing a few very
important variables well okay good
uh
i think all the
equations of relativity have
are
not that they're bung i mean i don't
care about them i'm saying they have
nothing to do with physics that's the
point okay you're not going to figure
out for example the rope model of light
of how the universe works with ropes uh
using equations of general relativity
all you can do is describe what's out
there yeah you can describe the visible
part and say mercury
rolls around the sun in in this manner
which is essentially what how what made
relativity quite popular and that's all
you can do you know but other than that
you cannot see what ties why mercury
doesn't leave the solar system that's
what i want these people to explain and
when they say well it's warped time
oh my god that's when i need a beer you
know general relativity is missing a few
very important variables you say i try
to publish my ideas to peer reviewed
journals over the years but because they
frown on anything to do with over unity
of energy
so i guess they uh never
publish the stuff in other words uh
large spherically shaped matter
producing new energy they rejected my
work
well yeah when you produce new energy i
can see why they rejected your work i
mean you know what what is this new
energy
what are you talking about how do you
create energy
you know uh energy is a concept
and yeah i create concepts every day i
mean yes easy
especially nothing the concept nothing i
create nothing every day so easy that's
creating something that's so difficult
you know anyways they don't want people
to know that energy can be easily
created
yeah you can create energy
in your head no problem no that's easy
imagine the benefits to being able to
freely make energy from scratch yeah
love it
in fact again i do it every day i create
energy constantly
uh
taboo i guess yeah yeah i guess it means
that if he creates energy somehow with
his little machine or whatever that he
runs all the oil companies out of
business or who knows
i not only discovered how to make free
energy but also what is causing the
accelerated expansion of space the
expansion of space
i didn't know nothing expanded how do
you expand nothing i mean you know i can
imagine a balloon expanding but when
nothing expands
it's because i had too much to drink you
know
along with why gas stars and satellite
galaxies orbit the
bare center of the galaxy's mass so
rapidly being so far away from the core
okay anyways i got tired of them
filtering out this now so i decided to
publish my own books good for you
[Laughter]
okay folks
i love these guys okay we'll see you
next
we'll see you next time okay bye bye